so so now go go 11 12 13 what happens
next again get arrested and i see
muhammad ali he comes and visits the
interest institution that i'm in
and that and i saw him and i got turned
out
i don't know how it happened in the
spirit boom i want to be like him you
said you're in jail and ali shows up i'm
12 years old and ali comes in he and
they showed the movie the greatest first
so this is 77
and um
after the movie the lights come up and
ali comes in and i see him i want to be
just like him
and then i get transferred from the play
staff so muhammad ali to this other
facility you know for real bad kids
and um
i met a german there that was a boxer
and he used to teach me how to box and
one day i broke his nose right and um
he got mad i didn't know he was mad but
he's mad that his wife didn't want him
to box me no more and that's why he was
mad so he took me to a great trainer
named customato and that's why i'm here
when you saw ali did you speak with him
was it like oh no
boom wow
that won't be like him
unfreaking believable so your
inspiration happened at 12 years old
yeah then you meet cuss yes how is cuss
treating you what happened for you to be
loyal what was his way of leading you
yes a degree of just peeling
all that
dirt and stuff that insecurity and
um
developing into character
and um
that's why i had a wonderful time with
him with everything about
everything about his life was about me
and so i never had a father but um i
know what it's like to want to make a
father happy and so i wanted to be
champion to make him happy but you said
peeling so that process a lot of us have
oh listen i don't know because this is
when i first came here i wanted to rob
the place
no when i
that's my life that's what i'm about
so when i first came in this is a man's
eye this old victoria imagine i said wow
you know i said what could be in their
drawers you know
that's just how my mind think even now i
have millions of my mind still thinks
that way but um
and i didn't know because he
at that time i didn't have any
self-esteem any character and he was
always saying look in the mirror look
how handsome you are today so i thought
he was a homosexual they were hitting on
me or something but i don't know he was
just building my characters allowing me
to love myself and um
we just had a great relationship for
seven years
um
i won a bunch of championships across
national championship he got me very um
worldwide known
and um i carried his legacy
was he was he somebody that would uh was
he direct with you would he be around
the book nothing straight to you no
[ __ ] so give me an example like how
would he talk to you
um
you don't want to be champ you're a
tomato can you don't want to work
you're sitting like that in here but i
cried to say that to me because the
major camp to me
it's not like it's funny yeah but tomato
can't mean
anybody's willing to blow you over you
ain't [ __ ] i got you
i got you so he was not one that would
be like you're amazing mike you're such
a sweetheart you're gonna be
he was
no um after i'm getting like um i'm on
the front cover of sports illustrator
right after i'm talking to us i'm
getting friendly with the reporters and
everything and the girls have my makeup
and i have somebody and then they said
take the blue my mom and clean the gym
he told you that yeah all the lights on
me like you know everybody see me i'm
all
cocky and stuff i'm on the front cover
sports illustrated um don't forget the
broom and mop mic
everything's humility
wow
i mean i've experienced that person with
a lot of people in the company yeah i
mean that's amazing make some noise guys
so
in your opinion
those who make it at the level that you
made it i mean the level that you make
it there's seven billion people in the
world that you're number one so it's not
like you're one in a hundred you're one
in a thousand it's one in seven billion
when you made it as a boxer at that
level do you notice a common trend like
right now i think it was mackie put up a
quote from michael jordan michael jordan
my biggest strength was
i'm coachable
i'm a sponge i want to learn i want to
get better do you notice the level at
the highest level is similar to somebody
challenges pushes to see that that
person wants it or not
i guess um it's cool that people are
seekers i think that's very interesting
that we're seekers but we have to
believe that we're divine and that we
learn from our experience because um
confidence breeds success and success
breeds confidence they go hand in hand
you can't accomplish anything unless you
say oh i'm a prick i could never do that
i'm not born to do it only certain
people go anyway people could do that i
can't do that
there's nothing i can't do you know you
may just be canceled after what you just
said right now oh man you can't say
something like that white people can
only do it because you and i i'm iranian
you're black we can't say thank you i
don't care i don't i don't care about
i got my own planet
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]